so if you look at the gallup
uh report a study will show that
when it comes on to the warren
commission from 1963
till today it's gone from people who
believe another person was involved okay
how many people people believe another
person was involved and how many people
believe
there was only one man involved right
the percentage was
used to be 29 that one only one man was
involved
then 36 percent then it went to 11 14
today around 60
65 to 70 depending on the year
believe another person was involved it
wasn't just
one man that took out john f kennedy
from your experience have been doing
this for so many years you've written
about it you've talked about it you've
talked about it
here at the you know in dallas to the
jfk music you've been all over the place
and spoken about this
where are you at now with your uh
thoughts on what really happened at the
event and was there one man two man
how did the events take place patrick as
the years have gone by
and more serious scientifically
based studies have been performed my
opinions
have been solidified corroborated um and
underscored there's no question that the
warren commission report
is wrong it's absurd the single bullet
theory
is a total joke if this were any other
case
a lot of my colleagues would have joined
me including back with the house select
committee on assassinations
forensic pathology panel in 78 would
have joined me
and attacking it but they decided
in some kind of a submissive place of a
placid
and passive fashion to go along uh the
civil bullet theory which holds that
one bullet produced seven wounds and two
men
president kennedy governor john connolly
zigzagged in the air right to left up
and down
um breaking two large bones in this six
foot four big bone texan governor john
connolly
emerged near pristine with a weight loss
of only one and a half percent
the entire copper jacket led core bullet
intact
except for a slight deformity at the
base from the impact of the firing
mechanism
that is incredible and if you don't have
a single ball of theory then you don't
have
a soil assassin but there are many other
studies
including neurological neurosurgical
radiological
photographic and acoustical the
acoustics evidence
itself is what led the household
committee on assassinations
back in 79 when they gave their final
report to say
that with all likelihood and great
probability that there
was more to it than a single assassin is
people don't know this
this is a bipartisan committee of the
top
legislative leaders democratic and
republican who came to that conclusion
and yet patrick got a darn thing was
done about it
absolutely unbelievable the acoustic
evidence clearly shows
and it was performed by the two top
outfits in america both
byranic and newman out of boston and
weiss and australizing in queens
college new york that the
shots came from both the rear and the
front and if you look at the reaction to
the people
that day in the zapruder film uh and
talk to people who were there
where did they go where did they run to
they ran up to the grassy knoll
behind the picket fence which is where
the second shooter was
it's all there uh and then when you
study things as i have done
from a pathological standpoint with
colleagues in radiology
and neurosurgery and neurology you see
the damage done to the president's head
by the way patrick the what what the
doctors that night at bethesda naval
hospital
concluded was far different from what
has been
have been observed by a dozen or more
top
surgeons at the parkland hospital and
in dallas these texas um
um surgeons with no axa grind
they describe what they saw in terms of
the damage to the back of the
president's head
the occipital area uh cerebellar tissue
which is that part of the brain located
and the rear and inferior
um and all of this was found to be
intact
by humes and boswell that night at
bethesda humes and boswell
career naval pathologist i want to
emphasize this clearly
had never done a single gunshot wound
autopsy
in their entire careers how does that
offend you
i have said i made this offer countless
times
to anybody you find any country in which
the king president
prime minister premier has been
assassinated without autopsy has not
been done
by the top medical legal forensic
apology people
in that country you won't find one
country at all
only in the united states of america
could they have so
so be so emboldened so brazen
so arrogant as they think they can get
away with this well they regrettably
have gotten away with it even though as
you pointed out
in your presentatory question commentary
that the majority of americans have
always
rejected the warren commission report so
i and my colleagues
we're not conspiratorial nut bags and
theorists
the americans who continue to believe in
the warren commission
they are in the minority so if you like
this sort of short club from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye
[Music]
you